she feeds Moscow's Street cats here
every day to help get them through the
winter there are cats hidden everywhere
here
activists estimate that over 100
thousand of them live on Moscow streets
and seek shelter from the cold in the
city's basements cat lovers lower their
food into the cellars so it doesn't
freeze in the bowls and when access to
the basements is closed off these animal
rights activists take up their crowbars
we're fighting because we don't want the
cats to die while we are filling out
forms or making calls if a cat is
outside and it's very cold - 20 yard 25
degrees Celsius then they can freeze to
death within 10 or 12 hours cause I'm
your neighbor
five years ago Anna Feldman founded the
organization cat rescue almost every day
now she gets a cat emergency call and
the rescuers jump into action thanks to
their commitment to Moscow's kitties the
deputy mayor of the city has even issued
a cat directive it orders small cellar
windows like these to remain open so
that the animals can climb in if the
vents are closed activists like Ramon
Palermo de feel justified in breaking
them open you do subconsciously have the
feeling that you're damaging someone's
property sometimes you think you might
be doing something wrong but everyone
wants to create a comfortable world for
themselves and for me that comfort comes
from cats and people who love cats if
you want to create that sort of world
you have to be willing to protect it too
Feldman does just that she's been caring
for Street cats since she was a child
she's even taken two of them into her
small apartment along with a stray dog
and she's turned her passion into a
profession such a miracle that a
predator essentially a miniature a lion
or tiger lives alongside people I see
little feathers chill a vehicle under
Feldman's soft spot for cats fits in
with the spirit of the times in Russia
she's even started a cat
school now with funding from the city
locals can learn about their feline
friends here how to keep them as pets
and how to help strays Anna organizes
the school with flood yamir Kuzon the
owner of Moscow's first cat cafe here
people can get to know stray cats and if
possible even give them a new home
surveys show nearly 60% of people have
at least one cat at home more than in
any other country worldwide still Russia
only just passed its first law on animal
rights last year our goal is for animal
rights to no longer be something that
just a few crazy old grandmas and
grandpas care about along with us of
course but that it becomes a natural
part of everyday life but not everyone
in Moscow wants the animals around
especially in their basements it's
probably not so good that they live here
they could have some sort of infectious
diseases but it's not their fault that
people abandon them for cats but they
are unsanitary of course that much is
clear
they shouldn't be living in the
basements should either be in people's
homes or in animal shelters we have
fleas Anna Feldman is fighting for a new
construction law that would protect cats
across Russia and not just in Moscow and
she has backing for her plan they've
noticed the cats on the highest level in
the city administration and even in the
Russian Ministry of construction and
they've recognized that opening these
basement vents is the only solution to
the problem the issue has gotten through
that far that means that they're aware
of the cats at the highest levels as Lou
analyzed it but until the feline
friendly laws open people's minds and
their basements Anna and her helpers are
determined to keep prying their way
through Moscow